chris hemsworth doesn't want to return
to the place where no man has gone
before in an in-depth interview with
variety he revealed the real reason he
turned down the chance to reprise his
role as George Kirk in Star Trek for
Hemsworth Star Trek character the father
of Chris Pines james t kirk only
appeared in the opening sequence of JJ
Abrams 2009 Star Trek reboot and his
character seemingly perished after the
Romulans attacked the Federation
starship USS Kelvin
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since then franchise fans have
wondered whether the Fallen officer will
ever pop up again in a future
installment unfortunately it sounds like
that isn't going to happen anytime soon
Hemsworth told variety that he turned
down the chance to star in Star Trek 4
because he didn't find the script
particularly intriguing or satisfying
more importantly it sounds like he
didn't think the storyline ultimately
earned the character's return as he put
it I didn't feel like we landed on a
reason to revisit that yet I didn't want
to be underwhelmed by what I was going
to bring to the table what's interesting
about these comments is how they
contradict an announcement Paramount
Pictures made about Hemsworth's
involvement in Star Trek 4 in 2016 the
studio claimed the actor would be
returning to Star Trek 4 as would Chris
Pine that announcement read in part in
the next installment of the epic space
adventure Chris Pines Captain Kirk will
cross paths with a man he never had a
chance to meet his father
Chris Hemsworth who appeared in 2009
Star Trek will return to the space saga
as George Kirk to star alongside pine
between then and now Hemsworth backed
out of the film as did pine evidently in
August 2018 The Hollywood Reporter ran a
story that claimed both actors parted
ways with paramount and skydance media
after the company's reportedly
backtracked on promised deals following
the disappointing box-office performance
of Star Trek beyond Paramount reportedly
modified Hemsworth and pines deals in
such a way that they both would have had
to take significant pay cuts
perhaps money was the major issue for
both Chris's but for Hemsworth it
evidently wasn't the only factor that
led him to walk away from Star Trek for
though it would have been truly amazing
to see Hemsworth return to the franchise
we understand why he ultimately declined
based on his statements it sounds like
he'd still be interested in reprising
the role for a future installment just
as long as the script was super solid
but based on what Hemsworth told Variety
it sounds like the way George Kirk would
have figured into the storyline of Star
Trek 4 was shaky at best
what's more Hemsworth has become a
household name thanks to playing Thor in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe at this
point it sounds like he only wants to
sign on to projects that he truly feels
passionate about since he's one of the
hottest names in Hollywood right now he
must be getting dozens of
on the hour at the end of the day Star
Trek force simply didn't tickle the
Aussie actors fancy and that's okay it's
not like he'll be out of work without it
sadly Star Trek 4 may ultimately never
get off the ground in April 20 18
paramount greenlit production on to Star
Trek features one from Quentin Tarantino
and one from British television director
SJ Clarkson but less than a year later
it was reported that Star Trek 4 was
quote cancelled indefinitely even though
the studio pulled the plug on the
project plenty of fans are still holding
out hope that Paramount will eventually
bring Star Trek 4 back to life but even
if they do decide to resurrect the film
don't expect to see him soar it's pretty
face anywhere in the film sweetheart
listen to me check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]